what's going on guys this is rob and
this week's episode of what if was
interesting but it wasn't nearly as good
as episode number four however i think
this episode did something
that what if episode four didn't in any
of the episodes didn't do which was give
us a much better indication of what the
purpose behind what f is in relation to
the marvel cinematic universe so the
things i loved about this episode i
loved the way that eric killmonger was
depicted truth to tell i never really
liked the way that eric killmonger was
done in the mcu now i loved michael b
jordan as eric killmonger but what made
killmonger so dangerous in the comics is
that he defeated black panther
even when t'challa had his powers that's
what made killmonger such just like this
enormous presence like holy cow this guy
defeated black panther
even when black panther had his powers
that's what made him so cool that in the
fact that eric killmonger was so
incredibly smart he was every bit as
intelligent as t'challa was i feel like
a lot of those elements were kind of
downplayed in the movie they weren't
really given the kind of credence i mean
there were things that were told to us
right when they're doing like the
overview of who killmonger is they're
like yeah he's really smart he went to
like mit and he did this and he did that
but the real thing is they call him
killmonger because he killed so many
people so he's dangerous but i was i was
kind of like all right i mean look guys
like let's play up the intelligence
aspect let's give the villains a little
bit more to go on than the fact they're
just bad guys who do bad stuff in this
instance i felt like this really showed
how capable killmonger was because his
plan was amazing right the whole plan
that he had in black panther was just
find a way to infiltrate wakanda and
while this was the same case to a degree
the lengths he went to were amazing
right like saving tony stark worming his
way into stark industries using his
contacts with tony stark like using his
emotional appeal with tony stark to
basically work his way up to becoming
like the head of security turning
against tony stark killing tony stark
like all this stuff was done for the
purpose of essentially having stark
build a giant droid army form so he
could use it to invade wakanda also i
think it's cool that he loves anime
that's pretty awesome right because we
basically got a gundam a whole bunch of
gundams and they were pretty cool
something else that was interesting is
tony stark basically just ended up
building the drones that we got from
iron man 2 so that was kind of cool also
how many times are they going to kill
tony stark the important thing here
is that we got to see uh chadwick boston
playing black panther again i feel like
black panther's role in this episode was
not really diminished because black
panther wasn't really built up in the
show that's one of the cool things i see
a lot of people getting upset because
they're like they had him kill t'challa
again yeah because the role of black
panther wasn't built up it was not an
episode about black panther it was an
episode about eric killmonger and tony
stark i think a lot of what we saw in
terms of killmonger overpowering black
panther was predicated on what we
already know about black panther and his
relationship with eric killmonger but at
the end of the day i thought it was cool
i love the idea that killmonger went as
far as to actually earn the trust of the
dora malachi and really the entirety of
the royal family in wakanda to turn
around and operate against them right
like that was kind of nuts because
that's basically what's gonna be
happening like i mean he is officially
the black panther now but i think he's
gonna end up basically conquering
wakanda kind of ruling it with a bit of
an iron fist but maybe not right i mean
what better way to rule if you're
looking to essentially you know subvert
an existing monarchy you know if we can
call it that then by then doing it in a
way to where they actually want you
there right i mean that's how dictators
would really succeed right like it's not
enough to just conquer a place you have
to actually get the people to want you
there because then you never really have
to worry about any organized resistance
against you right in fact you can
actually use the people to keep any
organized resistance from happening
against you right the people become your
weapon so it's a it's a pretty smart
move by eric killmonger now one of the
big issues i had with this tv show is
the plot hole that was presented with
shuri and pepper potts because there's
literally a point where they're like the
only ones that can really reason right
as they're like you know both our sides
are fighting and we kind of have to
bring them to reason and so you have
shuri who presents to pepper potts
evidence of what happened when eric
killmonger killed t'challa and tony
stark and you would think that she would
present that to like her family like hey
baba i know you're a big fan of eric
killmonger he's one of us but like let
me show you this footage where he like
killed t'challa and is obviously a
villain because he also killed tony
stark and then like hand eric killmonger
over to the us government either one of
these
is grounds for execution by lethal
injection like you would think that
would happen right where she would just
give that right it doesn't happen and if
anything that's not necessarily
something that you would expect from a
person who has been pawning himself off
the way that eric killmonger has he can
kind of interpret in a few different
ways truthfully that's one of the
drawbacks of the what if shows is that
there's not a whole lot of time for
development this one you have to be
careful you can go in depth but you
can't go too in-depth because then you
don't have enough time to explore the
stuff that you went too in-depth about
but maybe it's something that we'll see
later on having said that the ending is
really where the meat and potatoes of
this whole episode happens and the funny
thing about this is that it's easy to
miss because literally the episode ends
with the watcher being like all right
y'all i got to get to a meet and uh
we'll pick this up next week right and
then just he just leaves right he's just
like he's like and that's it so here's
the crazy thing about this right
the episode gave us this really cool
thing because we don't know exactly how
this is going to play out right it's the
most open-ended episode that we've
gotten to date so the only one that's
really equal to this in terms of being
open-ended is the episode with marvel
zombies right where thanos is standing
there with the infinity gauntlet on his
hand and then the heroes are going back
to find a way to cure the zombie virus
and to keep the infinity stones safe and
so you're like okay so like this is
going to lead to a great big conflict
it's easy to look at that and to say
these are things we're going to see in
season two and maybe we will honestly i
think we're going to visit these
universes and doctor strange too and
that's where i think a lot of this meat
and potatoes with the what if series
basically exists i mean the what if
series is also based on what happened
with loki right because it's one thing
to say the multiverse came back it's
another to say and do you want to see
what these universes look like like
people are like yeah definitely just
make sure they're good unlike the first
episode of what if so uh people are are
excited and they're enjoying this whole
thing but i feel like it needs to have a
a bigger thing right it has to be more
pop right more pizzazz than just like
here's a universe where [ __ ] pops off
like instead i think what we're gonna
end up seeing is a lot of these
universes visited in doctor strange to
multiverse of madness we might see him
for like 15 seconds we might see him for
five minutes i don't really think any of
the plot threads that were left open
ended in these episodes will be resolved
in doctor strange too if they are
resolved we'll end up seeing them in
season two but i think that a lot of
these universes that we're seeing here
are going to appear in doctor strange
too right you've got doc strange you've
got a secret defenders whatever roster
that might take i still say it all these
into avengers forever but whatever the
case is like you have them kind of
skipping through different universes one
of these is where tony stark was killed
by eric killmonger and eric killmonger
became black panther i.e what if episode
vi one of these is where zombies broke
out right a zombie infection broke out
because of janet van dyne in the quantum
realm thanos has the infinity gauntlet
he's all zombified right episode number
five like you're going to see these
different episodes crossing over i think
some of these are actually going to have
major roles in dr strange 2 which would
be the one that was left open with peggy
carter episode number one right where
she goes on to become a founding member
of the avengers most likely there's a
giant tentacle monster that we saw in
that episode and episode four there's a
lot of stuff here that could continue on
or or be visited in doctor strange too
and i think that's the important thing i
mean sure feigning in them came out and
they said you don't really have to watch
any of the tv shows to truly understand
what's going on in the movies but it
helps and i think it does i think that
if you if you're watching doctor strange
too and you come across some alternate
reality where eric here longer became
black panther after killing t'challa and
tony stark you're gonna be like what did
that happen and it's like well it
happened what if episode number six
right over there so go watch it when you
get done here right it kind of helps to
beef things up but it's by no means a
necessity but i think it's all going to
kind of cross over and build up and and
have some measure of involvement in
doctor strange too so with that being
said guys let me know what you all think
because i think this is a pretty
significant thing i think it's a pretty
big revelation right if if it wasn't
necessarily introduced in episode number
six it was introduced in five and six
basically confirmed it but let me know
what you guys think about this right
what are your thoughts on this whole
idea that the big purpose or the big
role the what if series plays is to
introduce alternate universes that we'll
end up seeing in doctor strange too let
me guys think thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace